mais d'abord les pilotes au chili tous
les mineurs ont retrouvé l'air libre
le dernier à sortir est en quelque sorte
le chef de l'équipe des trente trois
reportages franck jeunes aux autres y
sont le braz une dernière accolade avec
les secouristes et louis sol soit
embarque dans la masse tel film en
surface les familles n'ont jamais chanté
aussi fort 622 mètres de remontée et
celui que les 33 surnomme le capitaine
retrouve la liberté
le chef de quart luis urzua vient
d'arriver en très bonne condition
physique
c'est l'ultime étape d'un sauvetage
historique au bord des larmes le
président chilien s'avance pour
l'embrasser
vous avez été un bon chef dans le camp
espérant que ça c'est une explosion de
joie
la fin du calvaire
les mineurs sont tous sains et saufs
luis ochoa se fait alors le porte parole
des 33 j'espère que ça n'arrivera plus
jamais je suis fier de mon film et je
remercie tout le monde
les secouristes et tous ceux qui ont
oeuvré pour nous vive le chili dans la
nuit
l'ambulance qui le transporte à
l'hôpital a bien du mal à se frayer un
chemin au milieu de la liesse populaire
le capitaine va y retrouver tous ses
camarades pour 48 heures d'examens
médicaux
selon les médecins les 33 sont dans une
forme étonnante à tel point que les
autorités ont décidé d'écourter le
séjour à l'hôpital de certains d'entre
eux dans quelques heures deux ou trois
mineurs seront donc autorisés à rentrer
chez eux
et ce après 69 jours passés sous terre